this at the data science is a service
team in Delhi MC our team is located in
Belle Sheva which currently includes
nine data scientists all from different
domains all with advanced analytics in
different domains Computer Science
Industrial Engineering noodle science
and more we usually operate in a three
different but overlapping guidelines one
of them is an internal project in
terminal engagements with in Delhi M see
if it's developing recommendation
systems for customer support or QA teams
developing anomaly detection tools or
predictive models for these fellows and
other solutions that are used by
internal business units within Dell the
second line which I'm going to exemplify
today is external engagements both in
Israel and abroad and the third line
which is connect to the first two is a
creating intellectual intellectual
property and driving innovation in Delhi
MC by writing patterns and participating
in academic and and industrial
conferences so as I just said I going to
present an external engagement that we
had about a few months ago this
engagement was with an external US sugar
company a big company the business
problem that triggered this use case was
journeyed to predict the expected yield
of each of their sugarcane fields so
they basically they have thousands of
sugarcane fields spread across the
country and they want to know in
advanced how to allocate the the
resources human resources and
equipment so they can have the maximal
crop with minimum costs okay so this was
the business problem and actually they
had the starting point of this
engagement they had a model which was
also a pretty accurate but it tooks very
long it took very long time to build the
model and run it I mean it took about 24
to 48 hours to to train the model and
run it to every time and this is mainly
because they used the commodity was the
only laptop and the model was it was one
in an odd way to code they're written in
Al and they wanted to run it more
frequently I mean it wasn't enough for
them once a day although we can all
assume that it's not a real time a task
I prayed we want to predict the expected
yield of each sugarcane field at each
season in terms of tones pearl acres
okay because they want sometimes they
want to get a prediction in the
beginning of the season in September and
then they might say ok now we take those
first ten fields and then in October
they want to run the model again and no
but it can did it really frustrated them
to to run it sometimes for one day and
then it cost and yeah I mean yeah it
might happen even if you want something
for one day we all know it's a it can
stop yeah okay so yeah so getting back
to our objective we want to get a
prediction which are accurate and also
faster so I just give you the bottom
line because it's a show talk we managed
to develop a model that reduced
dramatically the prediction the model
training and prediction time from
24 hours to 15 minutes of course written
in a Python and part of it also in PI
spark just elaborate about it later
the main average percentage error of our
model which is the evaluation criteria
for this project was at 12.5% which is
slightly better than the model that they
had it was about 14 to 15 percent and
here you can see in this figure in the
overview for our solution basically
composed of three main components first
one is a data collection it's not really
component adjust the description of the
data that participated in our model we
used both historical I mean both
internal data sources like historical
data about the soil type planting system
plant age and a mini-mall which it was
basically an excel file of several
thousands of of records about past
seasons and we also add external data
sources about I mean that we downloaded
from public sources weather data which
is which also was pretty small and we
add the satellite images data from which
we extracted the metrics like NDVI and
ndwi which are indicators for yield and
the enemy wi can be extracted from
images and indicate for the level of
greenness on of the leaves or the level
of water in the field so after
collecting the data we it's digested by
Delta processing engine written mostly
in standard Python packages like vampire
pandas and we also use the PI spark
forward satellite images data and after
we vectorized the the features that
transform it clean it
engineers the features the vectors out
digested by a machine learning module
which is basically a competition among
different regression models and in the
end the customer or the user can get the
prediction for the desired time as a
dashboard which was developed by another
team okay so I just rubber ate a little
bit about the data processing engine and
the machine learning engine so as I said
for the data processing engine we used
for example weather data for extracting
features like a number of rainy days in
a season the maximum amount of day of
rain in the most twenty day of the
season story temperature etc and this
was conducted by a simple stand standard
Python packages as well as the
historical I groped crop data a previous
cereal the soil type etc it was pretty
simple but then and I think this is one
of the important takeaway is at least in
this kind of meet up we extracted the
satellite images features I mean the
NDVI energy WI and it was pretty like we
saying the Big Data zone ok so I think
that one of the good things walking with
the Python at least from my perspective
is that you can develop pretty easily
with standard packages like numpy and
pandas where everything is very
documented and well understood and then
when you have when you have a more
time-consuming tasks like extracting
features out of images out of many
images for a given field so you can move
your code to to the Big Data zone and if
you have a cluster over
a suitable environment you can write
several pi spell codes and then continue
developing with the standard Python code
okay so I think this is something that
pretty interesting in the context of
this project and after we and I've just
finished here after we process the data
as I said we have a machine learning
module in which we conduct competition
between several regression models the
model is trained over data prior to 2015
and tested on data from 2015 and the I
mean it was a POC so we evaluated this
according to this data and after and
after we choose the the model that has
the best performance on 2015 we give it
as the model for the next season okay so
I think that the models can be divided
to three families here the regression
models with the regularization like
discussed in the previous talk with
regression and Lassa and sample models
which perform better in this kind of
problem and it was I didn't said but it
was a 14 for 17 days and engagements so
we didn't have time to fully understand
the features we needed a plug-and-play
models I mean and in this case I think
that for my experiences begging and
random forests are the best because they
can eliminate the noise that you have in
your features and we had pretty noisy
features since we are not a domain
experts at at agriculture I think I'll
stop I stopped here if you have muscle
okay if you have any question you can
catch a statue about this project or any
other thing thank you very much
okay so this guy's natural astronaut was
face and saw these spots of light with a
little middle of the day the Mojave
Desert so of course the committed coffee
and some people had various theories one
can this be some say it's aliens and
Bigfoot and this one actually got its
writen actually our nation's so this is
there
[Music]
listen
[Music]
I don't pathologist there okay
shut it down for the conference - okay
so I'm Emily I work for a four byte
sociology and run the business of
specifically consecrated so about so is
each of these squares these photons and
deulim's about contains 50,000 sampler
kingdoms
hello stats and each one is about twice
this door for example and you can't
really see them in the picture and the
tower is about spot of light is about 50
meters right it produces each each of
them 130 megawatts which is about the
consumption of 300,000 homes ok so
basically they're the new on the caller
distance they direct the Rays of the
siding to the receiver and the receiver
is steam it's the steam and fit it into
a 2p okay so the murals like point the
sunrise into the receiver the receiver
boiled steamed and eats it and fit it
into a generator which produces
electricity and what I wanted to notice
here that the the receiver is not just a
single block it's gone it consists of
eight panels each panel has if they have
various purposes and for example in this
picture you see this
great black areas now just pummel that
are not being used they're not fluxed so
that's the actual color they're black
and the ones that are heated are glowing
so normally we wanted to point maximum
flux at the receiver to produce maximal
energy it causes maximal tricity and
maximal money but then you have
restrictions for example the turbine is
a delicate thing spoiled it likes it to
get it steamed right at the right
temperature and the right pressure and
you cannot change the levels of pressure
cannot change will fast and an other
part of the system also have
restrictions if you if you overheat made
from metals parts they made they made
Bend they called climate might cause
damage and after understand this
constrains the divalent time so what
what we need is a dynamic targeting
systems that strains aiming points to
each value starts it starts is capable
of tracking automatically following the
Sun but it needs to know where to point
so so you have to assign targets to them
constantly the question is can you keep
the the beam stable in cloudiness so in
cloudy days this is how the irradiation
at a single helix that might look you
see that it drops almost to zero and and
goes up again you can't have this you
need to somehow keep the beam stable so
the answer is of course yes but how do
we do that the aim is as I said the
aiming system can direct the targets
such that the beam will remain at the
points we want it okay but it needs no
special distribution of the radiation
and in the immediate future actually so
this is a
how it looks that the green line is
there like this single single heaviest
at and the the purple line is that the
average overall field so we
theoretically you have the right amount
of energy you just you have to point it
in the wrong direction so previously I
said how it looks on stability when you
look over the whole field you can see
pictures like that
now the actual data science I couldn't
get their permission to show just in a
short notice but i'm Ottumwa to show is
the these two roughly how I made it was
using this simple matplotlib hack okay
so because we have a short time and
probably had to skip right to the code
but before that and I do want to mention
what are the requirements the targeting
system was it works in in time frames it
sends a set of target every X seconds I
mean I know a 30 seconds minute if it
sends a set of targets and it know to
know in the upcoming up any timeframe
what will be on each point the average
the average DNI radiation and the Maxima
on each point so I basically have to
create two mats when estimating the
average annual answer okay so so I had
some title co2 to research a new
estimators but I did some plot with
monthly but then we want to make I can't
see them
yep
in a minute I'm going to show and how so
first of all it opens three plots this
is a Volvo I have sense all over the
fields and this one each of them shows
this one is the max estimate and this
one is the average ice teammate and I
can use the the keys if I press key down
it goes forwards I can go down to about
10 frames forwards and I can move to the
beginning at the end basically you know
you all have put back to a clip so you I
wasn't going to deals how you generate
these plots but what I want to get input
from the keyboard and I want to update I
don't want to write GUI I just wanted to
take the my existing code and to stick
some stuff in and and get this thing
that can show or it can actually be used
for for people to research what happened
during some events they just input the
time they want to see what happens from
this plant from this time to that time
it opens you can configure what exactly
to show in each of these plots and but
he needs to to keep this we plots in
sync and you need to get the input from
the keyboard which is actually quite
simple
[Music]
I have I have a link somewhere yeah this
is the points to the correct replacing
the McLean documentation cycle look for
yourself
and in the code basically the figure
object you can get the cam the canvas
and it has ampere connect you can just
this is a place for placeholder into the
into the event system of the back end
you know that much but what is can use
various a back ends but whatever
beckoned you use this will get you to
the event under so you can just insert a
key press event and if I have more
minutes I can well maybe I don't know
maybe show some more parts
maybe I'll show ya okay so load it down
so you have the head connect here and
the pressure the other thing is you
don't have to what I do if I made an
object these all these all plots they
share a keychain of objects also instead
of tying the handle to be to the on key
function of this plot they just looking
for that function okay it gets ya if you
get in the promote function if you get a
keychain then it binds it binds it to
the to the kitchen otherwise it binds it
to the on key function of this class and
the kitchen what it actually does is
remembers which objects it if you do the
key channel on key then it will call on
key for each of the objects is
responsible for hand and that's how you
get interactivity okay no I actually
because I didn't I didn't get proper
permissions I did it all quickly and
only got permission to present provided
I don't give her hand handouts but I
think actually some code snippets I can
I can I can give you a to publish just
that the the confidential thing is the
actual lecture plots and the actual data
because the data belongs to a partner's
not not only to us and after that
permission yeah
I actually didn't write I did this was
done some something like a year ago and
Jupiter's gone quite a lot over the last
year so I don't know it might even work
now because now now it actually has
interactivity I didn't want to press it
I just have made it work in the existing
yeah so the first situation which I
encountered was at work and what we
doing my heritage my team at least is
try to figure out with genomic data the
ethnicity of a person and I know nothing
about genomics so that was really hard
for me so I try to read some literature
about it and I saw this great solution
which I found really intuitive and it
was written in Julia and I know nothing
of Julia but I really wanted to use it
and the code is fairly simple even for a
newcomer and I basically what it does
you give it the genomic data and it
brings you back the feature which are
most important to get the the ancestral
classification that you want but I also
wanted to get the p-values for each for
each features so I just added this one
line of code and it was really easy and
I was really proud of myself and I
wanted to go from my level POC to actual
data but the problem was I had to get 15
million rows of data into Julia and the
richest V function there was like taking
hours I don't even know how how much
time we would have taken if I finished
using it and the problem using CSV file
is that when you got a lot of data it's
kind of slow to work with and you also
lose your meta data and you kind of have
to redefine everything sorry but
thankfully people kind of interested
that as data scientists work a lot with
data frames whether it's with Python
Julia or R and he'll awaken from that
built most of the packages which are
used in R and West makini that bill help
if the Panos library so this awesome
pretty pretty awesome package for the
feather format which provides a binary
comer culinary serialization for data
frame and it's designed to make reading
and writing data frames efficient and to
make sharing data across data analysis
language easy and it really does and
just to show you a quick example from
the blog post they posted after
releasing the package this is just an R
code and you can also find it in Python
which creates 15 700 megabytes data
frame and it takes about a second or so
and this was a pretty efficient for me
at least for my needs
sorry so after that I could go back to
our and write the data as a feather
format and then bring it back to Julia
and it was again really easy there's
just too two functions just the right
feather function and the read feather
function yeah so that was in Julia but
this is PI data so that's uh quite
Python so in work order I wanted to do
was use carrots because everyone's using
neural network so that seemed awesome
and I wanted to try it out myself also
but again like I did I was pretty new to
Python and I didn't know how to make
every column just as I wanted it to be
and the way I know how to do it in R and
so I just used the feather format again
to read the data in yeah there was this
slight thing of converting into numpy
but then I could go back to carrots and
do everything I wanted to do that all
the awesome pythons do so these were
just a quick example from my work but
they're not really reproducible and you
can take it home and try it out yourself
so I did want to bring something that
you could try out yourself so this is
just a really small example where I took
the this is Python code so you can all
be really excited about that
and this is just taking the iris dataset
and doing a short pca with with psycho
Soren which I really appreciate and but
then when I wanted to look at the
principal components I didn't find
Python plotting really intuitive to me
and I was really really used to doing
everything in G do clock which I found
really
vision so as you could just save the
data from of the principal components
and take it back to our to my comfort
zone and tidy up the date of the way I'm
used to and plotting it out and have my
pretty DD block yeah
so again feather is a great format and
it's fast but what I found about it is
that it's just a great way to explore
things outside of your comfort zone in
different languages I really like
scikit-learn about I don't think I'll
ever thought in Python so that was a
great thing for me but it just urge you
to all to try it out and explore
different languages when it's convenient
and right for the situation I don't
really work a lot with big data I work a
lot of ways to CSV file so I just needed
something that was quick enough for me
so I don't really know a lot of like are
you talking like per cat or something
it's pretty it's pretty fast like I I'm
not a I'm not a I'm not a computer
scientist so I don't know but a lot of
people use it for really big files but
it's also like in alpha so you don't
want to use it for a production or
anything like that so it's it's a format
but the package for using it is also
called feather and I think it's in
Python it's feather format in are just
feather in Julia yeah it's come it's
compatible with pandas and the data
frames in art and data frames in Julia
and it's I think built on Apache eraser
I think a lot of other languages are
going to use it as well thank you
everyone my name is Gibby I'm a
freelancer data scientist I'm very
excited to be here I do all kinds of
projects some of them in the
recommendation system area others in the
image recognition and one of my favorite
clients is a startup that is called
person Alex they do out-of-the-box
recommendation systems for ecommerce
sites so I'm going to show you a very
cool a Python package that is called the
light of film and it implements a
recommendation system you can already
know it and use it and it's a really
fast and easy to use and it's like gives
you a modern algorithm so in this talk
I'm going to start with some background
on the recommendation systems field
any of you views recommendation systems
okay not many
the thing with recommendations systems
that it's the most it's the most
commercial is the field very in data
science but it's much less sexy than
neural networks and images and stuff so
not many people they know what happens
in it they like many of you heard about
enough metrics competition and not not
much after this so commercial the things
they Facebook use the Tamils don't use
it everybody use it makes make a lot of
money of it but what actually happens
there so I have to start with the
Netflix price the next Express was a
competition of $1,000,000 that took
place between 2006 and 2009 the thing
was if you improve the Netflix a
algorithm by a 10% you will get a
million dollars so in 2009 some people
one of them from Israel even got this
prize the competition was over and there
was a model that this was the state that
is the best
model ever for recommendation systems
and everybody should use it so the model
is matrix factorization and from now on
I have many long words so forgive me if
I make mistakes but this is the model
and the tag that you took take a matrix
of users and the items in this case
movies writings that the users gave to
the movies you decomposed it somehow and
when you put it back together you'll get
predictions like here you get prediction
for Bob by item a1 we get three point
five so an interesting thing here that
the competition did include a lot of
metadata about the users are about the
the movies like age of the users or
genre of the movies but no one used but
I'm sorry not no one but the winning
completion did not use it so it was like
common knowledge from now on so you
don't need any metadata in a
recommendation systems just take this
matrix put it in the matrix
factorization and you'll have the best
model this was in 2009 so all the
companies took a try to use it and what
did they saw that the actual real-life
data is look looks more like this than
like this a lot more sparser you see
consider percentages on top many users
just come to one actions many items like
don't have a lot of views or any views
at all so this model was not very useful
it didn't got very good results in
things that they are not movies you know
when you go to youtube or you go to
Spotify I don't know if you are really
satisfied with the results so something
else was was needed and the new model
that came afterwards in around 2011 was
called the factorization machines so
don't confuse these are two very
different models the first one was
matrix factorization this is
factorization machines
and this this models the idea it had
medical tricks it is shown in this
article but I just tell the basic that
you take the matrix and you put it in a
different format like one hot and coding
format like if you have the users here
you put them a every users column every
movie as column and then you can put
decide features as as columns as well
and you can use everything in one model
and get better results than the previous
model so this is like now consider the
state of the out yes this models with
some with some tricks upon it people try
to do neural networks and stuff but they
didn't really catch catch here this is
the formula of it but you can read about
it in the article it's not very
complicated not having that and it's a
people say it's really one of the
greatest innovations in data science
because it's like really something you
know not like neural networks which are
all ideas but run on a better hardware
so now we get to light a film so a light
of film is a package that comes from the
industry it comes from a company that is
called somewhere list list is a fashion
e-commerce company and someone there it
took the took the factorization machines
idea implemented it in Python got very
good results the the library is very
easy to use like all the Python
libraries for data science you create
the model you fit predict you can
evaluate so now I will show you a short
use case of this model I will compare
the the factorization machines with the
model which one the Netflix competition
so the data set is data set of quench
questions and answers from a stock
exchange
it has 62,000 answered questions across
3,000 users who answered who can answer
70,000 items really sparse data set and
we would like to recommend users other
questions they can answer one more thing
that is available in this data set is a
tags like we have here a an example use
a question what should be the value of a
feature if it contain contained invalid
cases it is tagged as machine learning
and classification so I will try to run
this model once with the site features
and once without this wait without so we
need to close it for one second
I need to show you the notebook
okay
so
the first one is pure matrix
factorization I only put the data set of
the the matrix of the users and the
questions in a few were a few lines of
code
I run the training I measured there you
see and we see that we got the good an
you see on the training set around
ninety percent that but when I run it on
the test set which I took earlier
I see we get really poor results of
thirty five percent which is below
random so it's not okay it's not
something I would like to use now when I
take the model with the features it's
the same as before but now I put in the
fit function the item features it looks
like this the the matrix and then I get
in the test set
seventy percent so it's not perfect but
is it's much better than before so every
one of you if you want to do any kind of
recommendation system if you have an
e-commerce site or something or just
want recommend you music for your
friends you can take this take this
package put data in it and run it and
that's it so let's pick of the night
thanks for staying so late who here
feels like he has he or she has a pretty
good grasp of pandas you can go home and
have dinner with your families so as you
know we saw a lot of interesting walk
today but before the actual machine
learning mojo you have to do some
pre-processing you have to explore the
data you have to do some munching some
cleanup and for me the best way to go
about it was pandas and I'm a big
vendors buff so today I start I'll show
a few tips and tricks that for my
experience some people are not familiar
with I am this talk at the intermediate
user and I hope that you'll find some
interest here so that's
the table of contents hopefully we could
get to cover some interesting things
about me is I don't know if to say my
name is al O'Neill
I mean economists I left academia I went
to company called Claire's and then
until recently I was a guardian at bill
guard which was shut down unfortunately
and now I am the chief data scientist
the honey book Israel I'm also the only
one but still so let's go about it
pandas so usually you'd use the Technic
letter set or the iris data set I'm
using the Airbnb data set which is
basically some website called inside
there will be rigorously scrapes it'll
be in be all the time they have some
interesting visualizations and analysis
that should you should check out and
then Kegel took subset of that of
listings of Airbnb places in Seattle so
let's just get to it ready for my CSV
for convenience and the first thing that
I recommend doing is look at the info
which would give you a sense of how many
words how many non null values and
object types which is extremely
important when you look at the memory
usage so obviously this is a toy data
set with just under 4,000 rows but when
you get to 40,000 400 or 4 million then
obviously the memory usage is very
significant and we can see that with
just a few simple tricks that you can
actually minimize the memory usage quite
substantially so the first the most
important thing to remember is that we
want to avoid strings so if we can drop
string columns that are strings that we
don't need them and if we can evaluate
other cons objects to other data types
then we will save memory first in to be
aware it is boolean so we have host is
super host and the scraper didn't do
true false or 1 0 Z used actually actual
letters F and T and hopefully
unfortunately pandas obviously makes it
a very easy task to convert that to an
actual boolean so all I have to do is to
pass one host is super host equals
equals T and obviously if
it's tea then you'll get true if it's
false you got false and then this a
second you just converted an object to a
boolean
likewise for dates you should evaluate
to day time you can do it with the
built-in two data in pendant has and you
can also do as type day time and if you
are familiar with the data side you can
actually pass the data as we did from
the CSV side note read CSV has like 50
different parameters you can pass and
they are very very useful and finally
one thing that many people don't want to
very familiar with is to categorize the
column so you come here with that okay
so basically if you have certain values
certain columns that have just a very
very small subset of values that keep
repeating throughout the database the
data set then you should categorize them
and save out of space so for instance
the column room type has only three
different values that are repeated four
thousand times so with just as type
category you make that into a category
instead of an object and a string and
you can see the impact so I didn't even
do these transformations to all the the
different columns just for some of them
and for from three point six I'm now at
two point seven so that's like a 25%
reduction just like that and if I had
done the other things I probably could
have achieved maybe fifty percent so
that's that's to get you warmed up just
to read the data and optimize it a
little bit next filtering in slice in
the DFS so the ten frames everybody
knows about lock and I lock by the way I
X dot X is being deprecated next version
so FYI finally what's cool about the
categorization we just did is that you
actually can slice the boolean indexing
with the actual category so for instance
if we look at room type again we have
entire home apartment
private
shared room and with category
subcategories you can pass a list an
ordered list of how much do you value
the different values that field can get
so shared room I is the lowest one
private room it's a little better
entire home apartment is the best one so
you can do that and now you can do some
boolean indexing on for instance any
rooms that's at least as bad as good as
a private room so if we just runs that
we can see that simple
slicing with you know operators on
labels slice the data quite nicely I
think it's pretty cool and one more
thing is you can use red X so for
instance if you want to look only data
for columns that have info about the
host so just use filter like host and
you see all different columns of host
characteristics like neighborhood is
supers and all that and if you want to
do something a little bit more advanced
and you do have reg X like if you want
to see the different prices fees and all
that then just pass reg X that's it
that's pretty cool goodbyes okay so we
all know love use goodbyes
the couple of things that I think are
pretty cool I some of you are probably
familiar with the option to pass a
dictionary and have different aggregate
functions on different variables we
selection area now if you want to
flatten that the theoretical indexed to
just one flat level then it's obviously
Python pandas it's one of the things
that pandas doesn't do with just a
simple parameter but you have to
actually write three different ropes of
code but you can do that you get to the
level headers the second-level headers
we flatten them and what's really cool
about customer Kronk's about group
prices that you can pass a customer mark
funk so for instance if you don't want
to use Mean Max or whatever you want to
use something that you built yourself
then you can define a function either oh
pass an anonymous function and a group I
would walk so for instance let's say for
property type we want to group by
property type and have the bed type just
finished count the number of real birds
and then multiply it by 0.75 just you
know for sake of illustration and that
would work and you can also obviously
define a more interesting and convoluted
functions that takes you know whatever
you want and pass it inside the group I
and that would work and by the way one
interesting thing to notice at the data
set is that four tenths the medium
bathroom count is 0.5 it's interesting I
don't know I don't know what happens
there so we did that
oh and then I manipulate date
manipulations so one of the things I
really really struggle with these dates
because sometimes it works beautifully
and sometimes something breaks sometime
so let's just do a few date
manipulations we have two period so if
you have for instance daily records and
you want to see the month in the year
just use two period to period pass in M
which is four months here and the same
date is transferred in two months
and obviously the lots you can pretty
much pass whatever time frame you want
whatever frequency days weeks quarters
like five hours intervals and so on it's
very very flexible and you can also do
like date of week which is your based
which is cut which is cool
with sampling so what if you don't you
have daily records and you want to look
at them on a weekly level so you can use
resampling so that these are the daily
records and we can resemble them to a
weekly level which would just take them
and now okay some all the records for
that week just pretty cool you can
obviously use other functions as well
now let's say due to some data
corruption you lost some of the dates
some of the weeks then you can see that
over here you have 3 1017 and you don't
have the 24th of January and likewise
you don't have the first week of
February in the first and the third week
and so in the last week of February so
pandas has date range which gives you
I'm all of them which gives you you know
you can pass in two different dates they
start at the end date and the frequency
it will give you speed out all the
different data points date points then
you can use that and then pass that in
and reconstruct your data frame so now
obviously don't have no devalues you
have the web you have the values for the
different weeks but you don't know what
their values well so you can use you
know you can use fill in a with backfill
for to fill whatever you want probably a
much more interesting thing with Mbutu
you can do is like used feed into a
trend all that but that's that's not out
of the box as much as I know and finally
if you want to do you know week only
week months and months what I want
quarter differences again just one one
world in pandas with the DIF function
and they have it you can see that from
the wake of the tents to the wake of
between the wake of the third and the
tents then we grew from 34 listings to
83 and then you have a difference of 49
and so on I won't cover all these
because due to time constraints as I
said just notice that AIX is being
deprecated and there there's a lot of
unknowns about what's becoming the next
version which is probably because it's
just being built as we speak
that's pretty much it if you want the
code you can approach me you can find me
on any of the networks if you're
friendly you can do the same for
Facebook and
thank you for your time
[Applause]